the Resident Evil 4 remake gets a big
update good news it includes the
mercenaries mode bad news it has new
microtransactions in Mercenaries mode
your job is to build a combo to earn the
highest score possible as you play the
timer counts down but racking up kills
and keeping your combo going adds to the
clock mercenaries lets you play as many
of the game's most beloved characters
including Leon Lewis krauser and hunk
it's possible more characters will be
added later on the mode sends you into
stages across the village castle and
Island allowing you to relive certain
moments from the base game mercenaries
was also available in the original
version of Resident Evil 4 but has been
expanded upon greatly in the 2023 remake
with Resident Evil 4 becoming the second
fastest selling entry in the franchise
nipping at the heels of Resident Evil 6
with 4 million copies sold in only two
weeks Capcom is looking to capitalize on
its success with new microtransactions
this optional paid content comes in the
form of upgrade tickets which allow the
player to upgrade any weapon of their
choosing for free including the
all-important exclusive upgrade each
ticket costs three dollars with optional
multipacks allowing the player to buy
three or five at a discount speaking of
microtransactions let's talk about the
king of them Call of Duty Activision has
revealed a full road map for season 3 of
Modern Warfare 2 which Launches on April
12th the new multiplayer content
includes a brand new battle pass
gunfight and the return of the
intervention sniper here are some of the
highlights season 3 will introduce four
weapons to the game the battle pass
includes the iconic intervention sniper
rifle which is rebranded as the fjx
Imperium sniper and the Cronin Squall
battle rifle both Alejandro Vargas and
Valeria Garza from Modern Warfare 2
campaign will be available to unlock in
the premium tiers of the battle pass
more operators are teased to arrive
later in the season which will likely be
available as shop bundles multiplayer
will add cranked gunfight and GW
infected cranked is the fast-paced mode
that forces players to chain together
kills and stay cranked to continually
reset timer and avoid exploding and
gunfight is the chaotic 2v2 matchups
played over a series of fast-paced
grounds on small Maps while cranked in
the gunfight will arrive at launch GW
infected is scheduled for later in the
season this will be Call of Duty's
infected multiplayer mode played on the
larger ground wall Maps season 3 will
also add several maps to the game
including Three core maps 16v6 map
tailored for night vision two
large-scale ground wall maps and four
small arenas for gunfight full details
on everything happening this season
including the new black cell battle pass
on gamespot.com are you going to be
returning to Resident Evil 4 for the new
mercenaries mode are you still playing
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 let us
know in the comments below and we'll see
you here for more Gamespot news foreign